Heather and I began discussing covet as
biologists on Darkhorse and it resulted
in us quickly becoming demonetized by
YouTube which they've never reversed
even though they were wrong on the
substance of what they complained about
um and we feel their thumb uh or the
thumb of whatever it is that guides
YouTube their thumb is still on the
scale not only at YouTube but we feel it
at Twitter and I don't think that's
musk's doing I think there's something
deeply embedded in his machine that
still would like to keep us from
reaching an audience even though we've
been Vindicated across the board with
respect to what what we uh understood
but in any case corporate deep corporate
is the counterpart to the Deep State I
think it exists it's part of this
managerial bureaucracy that spans the
public sector the private sector the
associate deans of God knows what at
universities it's a it's a separate kind
of DNA and it's a different different
kind of gene pool it is the wholesale
capture of every structure on which we
depend there seems to be not a single
institution that has been able to resist
this the only thing that resists it are
small numbers of individuals who are not
beholden to anyone
mm-hmm and so that does raise a question
I do want to ask you I don't know your
position either during the so-called
pandemic or your position now on what
happened during the pandemic but as
somebody who had his life turned
completely upside down over these issues
I am very interested in what you thought
and what you think now and how would it
if it would affect uh your uh your power
in governance if you did make it to the
presidency
yeah so I think that
the
virus originated in a lab
in Wuhan China
it was engineered
and it was engineered by
a form of research
gain a function research that was banned
here in the United States
but was nonetheless funded in part using
U.S taxpayer dollars because of the
Rogue behavior of U.S government actors
in the Deep state
who disagreed with that policy
and taxpayer dollars in the law be
damned funded it anyway
under the excuse of preventing a global
pandemic
that gave us a global pandemic instead
then they funded uses taxpayer dollars
again
to fund the creation of vaccines
to prevent the spread of that pandemic
in the name of helping the human the
health of a general population
that ended up covering up many of the
health risks associated with that
vaccine it happened by no coincidence to
be some of the very same actors
that literally funded the creation of
the pandemic that then went on to create
fund the creation of the vaccines again
dressed up in the Garb of helping
Humanity
did not help Humanity in the way that
they professed to
and then we see the rise of
uh policy response
that
in the name of helping human Humanity
made all kinds of mistakes that leave us
worse off even along the very health
axes depression anxiety education of our
children obesity diabetes cancer
treatment and so on
that are net worth on health axes alone
let alone economic axes just Health axes
alone than they otherwise would have
been had we not adopted those policies
yet the very companies that were able to
censor any debate about those policies
were the principal beneficiaries
financially of those policies that
includes most of the Silicon Valley
establishment
so I could probably go on for hours but
in summary that is roughly what I think
is the some of the most useful parts
that we could actually learn lessons
from to stop us from making the same
mistakes again as I otherwise predict
we're well on track to with respect to
the culture of the climate to The Cult
of the climate that I think is in the
early stages of on track of repeating
the mistakes of the covid biosecurity
state I think we're now approaching the
beginnings of a climate Security State
that's going to repeat every one of
those same mistakes Lock Stock and
Barrel in their new form
excellent well uh you did spectacularly
well from my perspective having uh
watched and participated in the battle
over
covid there are a couple points I would
add to your list
um going forward
um the hardest nut to crack in all of
the covid landscape has been the
question of early treatment with
repurposed drugs where a large number of
people who have figured out that the
vaccines were not safe nor effective
still believe the propaganda that they
were fed over early treatment with
repurposed drugs
that's a very deep rabbit hole because
there is a reason that the propaganda
was so
aggressive with respect to this issue in
other words
the um
the release of the vaccines required
there not to be an alternative for the
euas to be granted so that is in my
opinion the reason that this has been
the hardest of these to clear up but
anyway it's worth looking into what
actually took place with respect to
repurposed drugs and also if you you
know
hydroxychloroquine and Ivermectin are
their own can of worms but even just the
failure to recommend
vitamin D for a population that is well
understood to be vitamin D deficient
and the massive increase in health that
could have been achieved relative to
covid if we had been honest about
exposure to Sun and if you can't get
enough exposure to Sun supplementation
with vitamin D that was a tremendous
missed opportunity and a very
frightening absence from the
recommendations because it literally uh
you know to the extent that there are
side effects to vitamin D they would
have been positive right it's an amazing
thing for us to have missed the other
thing that I didn't hear in your
description was the role that our
vaccination campaign likely played in
the evolution of viral variants in other
words did we produce an ongoing pandemic
of course we did though yeah by
definition right you know because and I
think that that acts actually deeply
related to being a man-made virus in the
first place
um of course this gets into the um into
the attributes of the way in which
attributes of a man-made virus that did
not naturally evolve in nature
themselves create risk of variance that
were at a different way of let's just
say um
you know let's just say evolutionary
microevolutionary change that's
different of a Kind than you had from
one that originated in nature right and
you know you have a generation
engineered versus drift and so on so on
yeah yeah you have an engineered virus
uh that one should not expect to abide
by the same rules that a natural event
would have produced and then you have an
absurdly narrow so-called vaccine that
creates an evolutionary signal that is
so uh targeted that you know of course
natural selection would overcome any uh
benefit from these vaccines because the
vaccines are just simply not broad
enough to create a difficult puzzle to
solve right selection is very good at
solving a puzzle and with a single
antigen that was guaranteed
but
uh
the last thing I would say is a couple
weeks ago Heather and I were prone to
look at the
coveted response in light of the
Nuremberg code which I'm embarrassed to
say I had not gone back and re-read
since covid began I knew that our
vaccine campaign in particular was a
violation because
uh informed consent was uh
was breached twice right couldn't
possibly be informed if they were
censoring viewpoints right you were
misinformed
and
it was a matter of consent because we
were coerced but when we went back and
looked at the provisions of the
Nuremberg code I was surprised to
discover that we appear to have violated
every single one of them
interesting these are Provisions about
which in 1947 even though they had not
yet been codified seven doctors were
hanged on the basis that we had violated
or that they had violated
um this obvious principle derived from
the Hippocratic Oath so in any case
um I do believe
that this is another one of these
examples of something that if you stand
in the right place and you look back at
our coveted response it's so clear
that what happened wasn't just wrong but
it was an egregious violation of a
central principle of medicine and not
even modern medicine but totally
stretching way back that it's it's worth
looking at it through that lens
um I agree with you I I think the fact
that there's people like you who also
now are not going to let this just go
gently into the night but make sure we
learn these lessons
is vitally important
for actually our
best way of preventing making that same
mistake in the future would be a global
pandemic or even a what I think is
increasingly made up change of
existential threat of global climate
change and
I'm with you on that I think that we're
just at the beginnings of
uncovering all of the sins that were
committed under covet some of which were
intentional I think some of this is
being attributed incompetence I think is
too charitable and I think that without
actual accountability
for some of the individuals who actually
committed the
most offensive of the sins who are now
being by the way invited as commencement
speakers this spring at prominent
medical schools oh God you know I think
that without accountability including
potential criminal penalties we're gonna
put ourselves at risk of making those
same mistakes again yeah I would also
say even if covid and medical you know I
agree with you this can't possibly have
been incompetence because incompetence
can get you to a effectively random
response it can't get you to the inverse
of a
correct response and in this case we did
almost the inverse of everything we
should do a t right to a t so
um but I also think even just going the
exercise of going back and figuring out
how our response to covet happened
is probably the best chance we're ever
going to get to understand the
corruption of our system because it
really does reveal the connections
between the broken governmental response
the universities and universities
science uh journalism the tech sector
all of these things their connections
are revealed by this story and so no I'm
not going to let it go because I think
it's very important that we use it to
diagnose the the illness that our system
has and to cure it
um and it sounds sounds like you are on
a similar page which I greatly
appreciate
amen my man I am I am I'm I uh
[Music]
it's probably the most enjoyable
conversation I've had in a little while
awesome I'm I'm pleased to hear that
[Music]